está en colombia y dicen que es el río
más hermoso del mundo disney lo escogió
en su película encanto como lugar en el
que surge la magia
las leyendas cuentan que un arcoiris se
derritió y le dio cinco colores pero
durante décadas fue también el balneario
de la guerrilla de las farc
ley de aguilares guía en caño cristales
cada día acompaña a turistas de todo el
mundo
bueno acá como vemos vemos las marca
líneas clave duras las que le dan el
colorido al caño en este momento están
rojas
estas plantas muestran su color entre
mayo y noviembre es un fenómeno único en
el mundo
en la macarena se encuentra en el escudo
de las guayanas el amazonas la orinoquía
y los andes' convirtiéndola en una zona
de hiper mega biodiversidad
este año se esperan más de 14 mil
turistas en 2012 ingresaron poco más de
3.800 bueno ha cambiado porque para
nadie delante decreto de zara danzan
agujas y donde mucha gente decía no voy
porque zona roja pero en este momento
como estamos viendo totalmente algo
seguro
lady es víctima del conflicto armado de
colombia los paramilitares mataron a su
padre ya su hermano pero el turismo
consiguió bajar el volumen de las armas
y apagó sentidos tuvo porque tuvo un
tiempo
además desarrollo
empleo ya como la tranquilidad más que
todo
caño cristales pertenece al municipio de
la macarena
ubicado al sur del céntrico departamento
del meta durante décadas no hubo
presencia de turistas pero si llegaban
desplazados de toda colombia para
trabajar sus fértiles tierras
[Música]
me alegra mucho
néstor hernández es uno de los primeros
pobladores fue líder vecinal y hoy
regenta este bar su testimonio es clave
para conocer el conflicto y el
posconflicto mejoró sin embargo
necesitamos mejorar mucho y ponerle todo
el corazón
al lado en la paz con el acuerdo de paz
de 2016 el estado a través del ejército
tomó control de la macarena y de zonas
turísticas como caño cristales pero en
las zonas rurales todavía hay presencia
de grupos armados ilegales
fue plan artemisa se generó aquí en la
macarena donde fueron cuatro casas
bombardeadas
carol álvarez y sergio cruz son dos
líderes juveniles han estado denunciando
los ataques del ejército contra
campesinos que viven dentro de los
parques nacionales les acusan de ser los
culpables de la deforestación que
realmente tenga en cuenta estas
comunidades y no solamente para atraer
ejército y policía sino para traer una
escuela profesores salud la paz atrajo
inversiones y turismo pero las
comunidades esperan una mayor presencia
del estado que hay una problemática que
es contra el gobierno porque de
ciertamente
llegan muchos recursos de la macarena
hay mucha comunidad
un proceso de paz y al momento no se
cumplió en absolutamente nada entonces
etc y por esa misma razón mucha gente
que se pare dice no más la deforestación
desde 2015 antes de los acuerdos de paz
hasta 2018 dos años después aumentó
cerca de un 92 por ciento en el parque
nacional de la sierra de la macarena
la tala masiva y los incendios son un
peligro mientras que cerca de la mitad
de la actividad económica de la macarena
es la ganadería
carlos garzón es guardia forestal de
parques nacionales de colombia
para llegar al de la macarena debe
cruzar el río guayabero un peligro para
cualquier guardia colectivo bajo amenaza
[Música]
peligroso entre comillas porque digamos
que una entidad ambiental en un lugar
donde ha vivido el conflicto armado de
manera directa
en 2020 fue asesinado javier francisco
parra uno de los coordinadores de la
zona y gran opositor de la deforestación
pueden observar un poco
que tenemos dentro de la macarena este
es un ejemplo de un incendio que acabó
con más de 3 mil 800 hectáreas de bosque
la pérdida de fauna y flora acelera los
efectos de la crisis climática y
nosotros realmente somos afortunados
hasta el momento pero sigue seguimos de
pronto dejando avanzar el tema de la
deforestación y pues vamos a terminar de
pronto con tierras áreas sin producción
de plantas donde pronto sembrar de
pronto también la comida o donde tener
de pronto agua para la
crisis climática que amenaza a los ríos
de colores de la macarena la subida de
las temperaturas puede provocar más
sequías que ponen en peligro a una
planta y ha maravillado a generaciones
no nos cansaremos de verdad y yo llevo
viniendo aquí 27 años de vida y aún me
parece la única me parece increíble la
manera en la que en la que sobrevive
su preservación es clave para el turismo
y el desarrollo de una región que quiere
dejar atrás el conflicto para siempre